في اكثر مناطق الاحتياج حول العالم كان
لرابطه العالم الاسلامي دور مهم في حياه
الملايين من الاشخاص الاشت فقرا ومن ضحايا
الكوارث والنزاعات عبر برامجها المتنوعه
والتي من ابرزها برامج الرعايه الصحيه
المقدمه للمرضى في عشرات الدول دون النظر
في عرقهم او دينهم فخلال سبعه اعوام وبين
العام 2016 وحتى نهايه العام 2022
استفاد من برامج الرابطه للرعايه الصحيه
اكثر من مليونين ومئتي الف شخص حول العالم
حيث نفذت 26 مشروعا تنوعت بين المستشفيات
والمراكز الطبيه المتخصصه والصيدليات
وغيرها في 16 دوله قدمت عبرها كافه
الخدمات الطبيه لاكثر من مليوني مريض في
هذه المناطق فيما وصلت برامجها التي بلغ
عددها 111 برنامجا لاكثر القرى النائيه
بعدا في 26 دوله حول العالم نفذت عبرها
نحو 34 الف عمليه جراحيه منها عمليات
قسطره القلب والعيون وغيرها لتغير بها
حياه مئات الاف المرضى
كما عملت الرابطه على تحقيق اهدافها
الصحيه عبر كافه الطرق حيث وفرت برنامج
المساعدات العلاجيه للمحتاجين بتحمل جزء
او كل التكاليف العلاجيه في دول مختلفه
اضافه الى عقدها شراكات استراتيجيه مع
منظمات انسانيه دوليه ومنها منظمه الصحه
العالميه واللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
للمساهمه في تحقيق العداله الصحيه عالميا
ومعالجه اجساد انهكها الفقر واخرى دمرتها
الحروب والكوارث